good morning john the project for
awesome is happening one week from today
it snuck up on us here it is surprise
every year since 2007
we've done a charity live stream 48
hours long lots of guests many goofs and
it's very fun and it is starting a week
from now here on the vlogbrothers
channel at youtube.com
vlogbrothers maybe you're thinking i
know all this i know all about the
project for awesome i don't need to
watch this video please watch this video
we have changed things it's going to be
different this year than it ever has
been
and i want you to know about it first
difference we are going to be using a
new platform for
our fundraising portion of the event
it's called tiltify it's designed
explicitly for charity live streams
because
the like that's the world we're in now
this is exciting a huge portion of the
money we raised during the project for
awesome is people donate money and in
exchange they get perks and that will
all happen until define now the tilted
fight will be open
on wednesday of next week you can start
seeing all the perks that are available
then
though it won't be everything i wrote a
short story for the project for austin
this year called bonker doesn't die in
which april may the main character from
my books goes to vidcon and has to uh
rescue
a pig a celebrity internet pig because i
can do that so head on over there next
wednesday it will be open during the
entire project for awesome of course
these are all things that are only
available during project for awesome and
during some portions of the event your
donations will be matched so you might
give ten dollars for my tick tock trash
but it's gonna become thirty dollars
for charity money raised during the
first half of the project for awesome
will go to save the children and
partners in health two organizations
that are very effective
at decreasing the overall amount of suck
in the world during the second half of
the project for awesome the money will
go to organizations voted on
by you maybe i'm getting ahead of myself
there are four ways you can participate
in the project for awesome number one
you can come and join our live stream
tell people about it
change your twitter bio make sure
everybody knows and they come and they
hang out and it's fun number two you
could donate money you could do that at
the tiltify which will open on wednesday
and you'll get perks in exchange for
your donation or you can just donate
money at fightworldsuck.org or if you
want to give a larger amount like you
want to be part of our matching fund you
can email us at ftdws
at complexly.com foundation2decrease
worldsuck complexity.com matching funds
can only come in until
12 p.m eastern time on february 10th so
email us before then third you can make
a video promoting a charity
that you are excited about and believe
in previously we opened submissions for
those videos
the day the project for awesome began we
are not doing that anymore that was like
a relic of the time when we were trying
to game the youtube algorithm which
hasn't been a thing for like 10 years so
to give our volunteer team time to go
through the videos and decide which ones
we might want to feature during the live
stream
we are getting those submitted early
this year so make a video talking about
the impact the organization has it has
to be made specifically for the project
for awesome and you can submit it at
projectforawesome.com we got tips for
how to make great videos there we got
graphics you can use but you have to
submit them by noon eastern on february
10th so you got less than a week to do
that but hey
every vlogbrothers video is made in less
than a week and finally at
projectforawesome.com during the live
stream you'll be able to vote on your
favorite charities to determine which
ones are going to get
part of the money we raised during the
second half it is the most wonderful
time of the year thank you in advance
for joining us
whether you do one or none or all four
of the things thank you for being a part
of this community i'll see you during
the livestream it's gonna be a very
silly time starting on february 12th
at noon eastern time john i will see you
on tuesday and i will also see you
next friday i'm trying to dab i can't
there's some invisible force that's
preventing me from dabbing oh well
that's probably just age i can't do it